[Music]
descendants three will introduce us to
some brand-new characters but let's be
honest we're pretty much all excited to
see what dr. facile ears family will
look like here's a little sneak peek of
what we know so far Mirror Mirror our
future holds don't forget to hit that
notification bell to never miss another
video and be sure to check out our
community section for even more fun now
let's check out what we know about Celia
fassl ear who is Celia okay let's start
from the very beginning we all know who
dr. facile ear is right a tip of the
hand from dr. Fazzio well if you don't
we suggest Yuri watch The Princess and
the Frog he's one of those Disney
villains you'll kind of hate but kind of
love too unless you saw descendants
wicked world animated short you probably
didn't know he has kids well he does and
Celia is one of his children we don't
really know much about her at all but by
the sound of it she'll either be a
spitting image of her father or a
complete opposite Disney has managed to
keep everything under wraps including
things like her age and personality what
we do know is that Celia is clearly a
villain kid which means she must live on
the Isle of the Lost
some fans seem to suspect that she is
actually the same age as dizzy and that
we might see an art on prep storyline
with these two we'll have to wait and
see how all of that plays out won't we
okay so what else do we know about Celia
family by now you should know that Celia
is the daughter of the one and only dr.
facile ear one thing's for certain if
we're getting dr. facile ear in this
movie it means he'll probably have a
pretty big part let's not forget just
how evil and manipulative he is there's
no way his role is going to be small
honestly we're super excited at the fact
that we'll get to see a human version of
his character he's just such a well
written and thought-out character we
have a feeling it'll be hard to portray
him in his cartoon style but let's give
back to the whole Fassler family dr.
facile ear also has another daughter and
her name is Freddy you could actually
see her in the descendants wicked world
animated short Freddy is definitely her
father's daughter in the sense that she
has a very
similar personality and agenda I meant
why are you stealing that when you could
be stealing this while we do know quite
a lot about Freddy Celia is pretty much
a mystery which is perhaps why she was
chosen for the third movie yep that's
right by the looks of it Freddy won't be
in descendants three as of October 2018
the cast list has only been updated with
dr. Vasily R and Celia are you excited
to find out more things about dr. Basso
airs second daughter we also don't know
anything about the mother either but it
doesn't look like she's the focus of the
story isn't it strange how a lot of
Disney villains are single parents who's
the actress the role of Celia belongs to
an up-and-coming actress that goes by
the name of Jada Marie she's absolutely
adorable Jada comes from a large family
and is one of nine siblings she also has
twin brothers who are both actors
doesn't it kind of remind you of the
loud house anyways data has shown
interest in performing since she was
four years old which is pretty
impressive apart from acting she also
did gymnastics and cheerleading her IMDB
page said that she was a cheerleader at
only 4 years old we wonder if she'll get
a chance to sing and dance in
descendants 3 or perhaps too many stunts
her talents would definitely help her
with that and we really hope Disney gave
her a big enough role although her CV is
fairly short she did land a spot on a TV
series called man & wife which has been
running since 2015 it's very clear that
this talented kid definitely has passion
for acting and we're pretty sure
descendants 3 won't be the last time we
hear from her but what will we hear in
descendants three storyline so one could
be a potential storyline for the third
movie as we said Disney's been keeping
this one under wraps and so far we only
got the under-the-sea short as our guide
but even then we don't know much however
we have a feeling that the fans might be
right on there speculation of Celia
storyline caelius actress looks to be
about the same age as dizzy which could
potentially mean that celia is in the
same age range and we all know that
dizzy is going to our Don Pratt so what
if Celia got the are Don Pratt
invitation - we also have a feel
that Caelius personality will pretty
much determine how big of a part she'll
play in the movie if she's anything like
her father she might be up for some
mischief but if she's one of the good
gals like dizzy they might just briefly
show her since Freddy is the daughter
that seems to be more on the evil side
Disney could definitely do a twist and
give her non evil traits it happened to
dizzy and they can definitely do that
again after all that's how you balance
out the family right if there's anything
we learned it's that everyone has a bit
of good and bad in them it all depends
on what you do with those traits
either way we really hope we get to know
Celia and give her a storyline if her
sister Freddie has a storyline in the
animated short why shouldn't we get to
know Celia on the same level too but
that's just our theory what do you think
of Celia does she have a big role or
will she just show up on screen for a
couple of minutes do you think we'll see
her in auradon prep or will she be up to
no good on the Isle of the Lost
share one of your theories on what will
happen to her in the comments below
let's talk about it you know how much we
love to talk about descendants with all
of you and that's it for our video don't
forget to subscribe to the things for
more videos like this one thanks for
watching see you next time
[Music]